do you see what happened to Anthony
Jeselnik no I didn't
they're attacking Anthony Jeselnik
they're attacking a bunch of people for
tweet jokes after James Gunn got fired
you know James Gunn is he's the guy who
is the director of guardians of the
galaxy yeah he had some really
questionable tweets there were jokes
there just he wrote some jokey joke
things but it's like about pedophilia
like oh I didn't see that yeah like a
why did see there was like a huge yeah
screen of them copied and pasted yeah
yeah they're [ __ ] terrible yeah the
problem is they're not funny yeah and
their jokes and they're really gross but
should he be fired for that no he's just
a shitty joke teller if you find out
he's actually a pedophile that's one
thing yeah it's Disney in this today's
climate so then they find that Anthony
Jeselnik the stand-up comedian has a
bunch of also offensive jokes and some
of them about pedophiles and so they go
and try to attack him and Anthony
Jeselnik writes looking through my
Twitter timeline something along like a
needle in and yeah he said looking is
like looking for a needle in a needle
store on customer appreciation yeah yeah
it's so true waste his whole [ __ ]
thing is his character like Anthony Jess
and I can protect my friends with him
his whole thing is being ruthless and
super offensive hmm like he had a show
called the Jeselnik offensive mm-hmm I
mean that's what he does
mm-hmm he said I mean his character is
an awful person that's the character and
so that's gay well it's totally lost on
people now right you can't you just
can't say things period well they're
looking for people to back down and
they're looking for people to get scared
and I mean this is it's fun it's fun to
find a target mhm and find of all let's
get him fired get her fired take her off
that movie it's fun for them because as
you know hashtag air quotes activists
what they're doing is they're just
attacking mm-hmm and there's probably
some good out of it but look there's got
to be some good for sure out of real
monsters getting arrested right there's
there's some good out of like the Harvey
Weinstein's and the Bill Cosby's the
getting arrested and getting busted and
shutting down and we would hope that
other monsters in waiting would not act
out on their instincts because of the
fact they're worried about the
repercussions that you're clearly seeing
and that we would hope that people that
our behavior as a culture shifts one way
or another and then it's going to move
as far away from misogyny as possible
and it's whether it's through the threat
of incarceration or shame or whatever it
is that causes it to go the other way
it's probably for the best as long as it
doesn't go as far as all men are pigs
yeah all men are creeps all men are
trash and that's what we were talking
about earlier like when it gets to that
place you got to go well this is not
this is not a good place to be well also
if there is an allegation that that's
taken at face value right away because
we do see unfortunately that some of
these allegations are false well it has
to be this whole idea of believe women
well okay but okay does that mean don't
believe men because some women lie and
some men lies
what about individuals what about human
beings and so if we're going to meets
what we're talking about earlier like
white power or black power brown power
boats [ __ ] human beings as soon as we
stop looking at human beings as
individuals and we just agree that one
group is good and one group is bad
you've got some real discrimination
problems yeah well you can't win in that
way either because you can't look
whether you side with believe all
victims or I believe what is it I
believe women or something like that
yeah there's a hashtag believe women
believe so but I believe survivors or
something like that right and then or if
you say you want due process and women
lie and you know that side of the
equation I think even both sides are
equally bad because you're not getting
at the truth